we should we should take this Advantage
I'm just realizing now yeah you know
because we have a live studio audience
and sometimes we do these shows and
people always like why didn't they talk
about that anime so if you guys make
some noise for which anime you want us
to talk about we'll talk about it just
go crazy start shouting things
[Applause]
I heard JoJo okay we'll hear another
did I hear that that's just your JoJo
brain here right now I can only hear
JoJo okay do it again do it again
[__] I just heard JoJo again
that one JoJo fans so goddamn loud how
could you sell so loud with a dick in
your mouth huh
so we want to talk about Jojo
what
anything what is there to talk about
yeah the only thing we we're going to
say about JoJo is that uh all of you
should be watching it
doesn't matter what kind of anime you're
into you should give it a go did you
hear anything else uh did I did I hear
oh
[Applause]
oh it's so good it's so good [__]
amazing yeah so I mean it's trying on
like I and it's Studio orange and I'm
like yeah match made in heaven uh yeah
so I came in to try gun uh obviously not
remembering much of the original series
that aired like I feel like a decade or
two ago right now yeah so I didn't
remember much and I feel like that only
helped my experience with Trigon
Stampede because not only does it take
kind of a different direction to the
original Trigon yeah it also does things
that the Trigun the original Trigun
never covered as well yeah yeah yeah and
uh all I can say is it's [__]
incredible Studio orange somehow has uh
knocked it out of the parking lot I
don't know like I thought they would
like achieved peak in B stars and then
they were just like hold my beer with a
Trigon because oh my God it's like it's
just that last episode especially I've
obviously not going to spoil it but oh
my God that lot there's a lot there's a
scene in the last episode where Studio
orange just flexed the [__] out with
their animation and it looks insane yeah
so please give it a watch like would you
say would you say you can watch Trigon
Stampede without necessarily watching
the original oh you don't need to watch
the original yeah in fact I think it
might be better if you don't watch the
original show uh because it's two
totally different Vibes yeah right did
you get that as well yeah no absolutely
like I feel the the original trigger was
very much like you know the the Western
you know the spaghetti western aesthetic
that you know it was was present in it
and then with like hints of sci-fi
whereas Trigon Stampede is just full-on
sci-fi right there's like a little bit
of the kind of spaghetti western feel to
it but it's just like they they did the
uh they did the trigger effect basically
they were like we're going to space
[Applause]
original Tryon
okay all right Edition man okay so even
if you didn't put your hands up please
give try on Stamper to go you don't have
to watch the original it is insane
insanely good it got me to watch it
I don't know if I just imagined this but
I imagine it's popular enough that
someone said it did I hear Attack on
Titan as well
and I never heard about it what's that
that's the that's the quietest anyone's
ever been for attack yeah whenever we
say Attack on Titan in the states you'd
think that like you just got a new
president they were just like
yeah I think it's because Americans they
just shout when they know something
they're like I know that show yes
uh yeah that's good
what'd you think Joey my favorite part
about attacker Titan is uh having to
wait 500 years for anything yeah I can't
wait for that finally ending now we only
have to wait a few more months
[Applause]
and then they're going to bring out two
movies and a [__] OVA or something I
don't know that's they're gonna milk the
[__] out of her for sure it's taken 10
years
has it wait Has It wait yeah it has been
10 years hasn't it yeah yeah yeah I mean
okay
how big do you think the ending is going
to be for Attack on Titan do you think
like how much is it going to blow up the
internet I feel
it feels me or
you don't hear as much about Attack on
Titan anymore as like the first couple
of Seasons because of the whole problem
of them like milking it out but also
just them taking way too goddamn long to
like get to the point you know so like I
don't know if they've like shot
themselves in the foot in that regard of
go like I don't know like is it just me
like you don't there's obviously people
talking about Attack on Titan right but
I don't feel it's nearly near the peak
that it was during like season one for
instance right uh I would still think
it's still super [__] popular oh it's
still super popular more popular than
like any anime I would argue and not any
anime but it's definitely like up there
like I think after like the top two like
seasonal anime it's like it's there in
like the top five at least but like I
don't know I remember when like season
one came out oh my God like my grandma
knew what the [__] Attack on Titan was
like that that [__] was everywhere
especially how did your grandma know
about it because my oh my Japanese
grandma is like she's actually quiet she
loves demon slam what yeah Your Bass
grandma Yeah my best grandma my grandma
my uncle my aunt they're like all fans
of demonstrate my dad's still trying to
figure out what anime is like he's like
I've watched 10 I don't even know what
it is
all right Joey real questions you know
what's airing next season
no jiu jitsu Kai since
yes are you gonna be watching jujitsika
Ice in season two Joey you know what I
actually will
are you actually yeah are you actually
but he called it mid yeah I still
finished season one though
I'm going to watch season two so that I
can further confirm how mid it is no
can we get a boo can we get a boo for
that
thank you
I don't know if you ever explained why
you think it's just mid or you were just
like
do you have an actual reason like I
think for me it's it's completely like
like unprecedented like my reasoning
behind it like how do I feel how I feel
better
I've never had someone refer to their
own opinions as unprecedented this is an
unprecedented it's unprecedented because
like okay my the the how I feel about
Jesus Christ and right is how I felt
about
um what's the one uh with uh senku the
main character
Dr Stone that's how I felt watching Dr
Stone is how I feel in Jesus geising in
the sense that I I looked at the
synopsis for both shows right and like
the background of it all and it ticked
off all of the boxes of what I like in
an anime right and so I was like well
obviously this is going to be a great
[__] show I'm going to enjoy the [__]
out of it right and then you start
watching it and it's just this feeling
of like
this is not quite what I wanted and it's
really difficult to explain it's it's
like literally A vibe check like I'm I'm
Vibe checking Dr Stone and Jesus okay
and I'm being like
I know this has all the things I love in
it but some combination of this I don't
know where it is or what it is it just
doesn't feel like the show that I was
hoping it was going to be you know like
I got the same thing with Carolyn
Tuesday
okay when I watched Carol on Tuesday I
was like okay it's what's on our machine
churro amazing writer it's about music
it's you know it's it's sci-fi it's like
this is everything I [__] love in an
anime and I watched and I'm like
it it was good but like something's
missing and I don't know what it is do
you get that feeling I I actually no I
agree with you yeah I had such high
expectations with Carolyn Tuesday Yeah
just something about it just didn't hit
the story beats I wanted exactly well I
do want to re-watch it because uh I
remember Caroline Tuesday and it this
synopsis or the premise of Carolyn
Tuesday is actually scarily accurate to
what's going on now so if you don't know
if you haven't seen Caroline Tuesday uh
it's a exploration about
real music and musicians versus music
that is AI generated
very topical today it is it is very very
topical today because uh let's be honest
we're going to replace we're going to be
replaced by AI in like five years right
we've all heard that Drake and weekend
AI song right yeah that [__] slapped
yeah yeah like I think I think my
favorite meme right now is the Harry
Potter like not the Harry Potter the
Balenciaga AI memes oh my gosh that was
Harry Potter no no because because
they've done collaborations yeah with
like Harry Potter and like all these
like movie franchises of like all these
movie characters basically AI generated
into like Shilling out for Balenciaga
it's the weirdest thing you're looking
up when you get up and then there's the
recent presidential like debates Oh no
just like the president AI generated
conversations like OverWatch and stuff
like that yeah
they like playing Minecraft and [__]
yeah yeah that's just close yeah no I I
agree like and so like how I felt about
like Carolyn Tuesday and like Dr Stone
is basically how I felt about Jesus
guy's name like right in the sense that
it's like I I actually hate the fact
that I think it's mid because I it was
everything that I wanted in again no I
do and it's like I hate the fact that I
think that because it's like again it
was everything that I thought I wanted
in a new Shonen and just something about
it didn't click with me and I don't know
why and that's why I hate trying to
explain why I Think Jesus Christ said
it's me it because I know it's just a me
problem it's just the meaning it's just
it is
and I totally understand why people love
the [__] out of it because I wish I was
there too but I can't I swear to God Joe
I I know for a fact now if you ever get
to watching Arcane you're gonna think
it's me yeah I swear to God Joe I'm not
watching you know maybe I'm doing a
service by not watching it no he should
watch out he should he watch Arcane
okay but all I'm saying is don't yell
and Shout at me when I come back and say
Arcane is mid all right you forced me to
watch it boom
thanks guys
you guys will do anything
is so much better when I can command
people to move yeah I can just be like I
don't like that opinion boo guys
this is what Connor gets when he has a
live twitch audience in front of him
yeah you've given him too much power way
too much power